Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Es ist wieder Zeit für die Ligatur. Wir blicken auf die europäischen Top-Ligen und heute auch mal ein bisschen auf so manche Nationalmannschaft. Das ist doch mal was Neues hier in Rasenfunk Kurzpass 254. Hallo und herzlich willkommen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost. Ich bin der Ed Genetzer auf mastodon.social. Und wenn ihr immer noch bei Twitter rumhängt, dann auch dort. Ich begrüße euch sehr zu Rasenfunk Kurzpass 254. Es ist mal wieder Ligaturzeit. Wir haben hier eine tolle Runde an unterschiedlichen Gästen. Ich begrüße zu meiner Linken Christian Bernhard. Hallo Christian. Ich begrüße nicht ganz zu meiner Linken, sondern zugeschaltet, wobei örtlich gesehen ist er trotzdem immer noch links von mir, nur ein bisschen weiter. Uli Hebel. Hallo Uli.
Ich kann das nicht nachvollziehen, weil meine Orientierung dermaßen schlecht ist. Aber grüße euch.
Glaubst mir, irgendwann, als es darum ging, dass du irgendein technisches Gerät gebraucht hast, habe ich mal kurz geguckt, wo du wohnst und da… Also es ist grob links von mir. Lassen wir es so gelten.
Das stimmt trotzdem eher Ost oder West, oder mein Lieber?
Der Geografie-Lehrer des Rasenfunkes ist auch hier. David Frogier de Ponlevoy.
Ich hatte ganz schöne Rummelplatz-Vibes bei dir, als du in der Einleitung warst. Das ist noch mal was Neues.
Noch mal rückwärts für 5 Mark, auch mit Alex Truica.
Hallo Alex.
Die Stimmung ist fantastisch. Wir hatten schon sehr wichtige Vorgespräche. Es ist wirklich nie Jammer, dass dieses Mal die Aufzeichnung nicht schon vorher lief, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Aber ein bisschen was, das könnte vielleicht die Finanzierung für den Rasenfunk sein. Also da machen wir doch eine Paywall, aber dass man die Vorgespräche, die kriegt man für, muss man den Preis aber hochsetzen. Also wenn ich das Vorgespräch heute so angehe, würde ich sagen 50 Euro im Monat.
Ich dachte, du meinst das eher umgekehrt. Du erpresst uns dann damit, dass wir was bezahlen, dass du die Vorgespräche nicht veröffentlicht.
Ach so, ach nö, dann gibt es ja keine Vorgespräche mehr. Naja, wir lassen das. Also liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, ihr wisst aber, der Rasenfunk braucht eure Unterstützung. Rasenfunk.de slash-Supporters Club, bitte unterstützt uns nachhaltig, denn es lohnt sich und es kommt nicht nur dem Rasenfunk zugute. Im März werden wir 1.625 Euro an Honoraren überweisen. Ich habe nämlich diesmal schon alles vorbereitet, damit ihr alle euer Geld schnell bekommt. Also liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, ihr seht, das, was ihr dem Rasenfunk zugute kommen lasst, das fließt nicht in meinen Palast hier. Bernie kann es bezeugen, an dem hat sich nämlich gar nichts verändert in den letzten Jahren. Sondern es geht auch an die Gäste. Bitte unterstützt uns Rasenfunk.de slash-Supporters Club. Jetzt wollen wir reinschauen und wir haben die Besonderheit, dass wir mal eine Ligatur aufnehmen, nachdem auch die Nationalteams unterwegs waren und zum Teil sind sie sogar direkt aufeinander getroffen. Wir haben da unter anderem Bernie ein Spiel gesehen zwischen Italien und England, bei dem England mit 2 zu 1 gewonnen hat, obwohl man in Unterzial gespielt hat und obwohl Italien ja auch durchaus einiges wieder gut zu machen hat, kann man glaube ich dann doch schon so sagen. Was war da los?
Ja, es war einiges los. Also es war ein Spiel mit zwei komplett unterschiedlichen Hälften, also Halbzeit 1 ganz, ganz klar in England, 2 zu 0 geführt, zweimal nach Standards, hätten eigentlich kurz vor der Pause auch das 3-0 machen müssen, Riesenchance, die Crain super rausgespielt hat. Dementsprechend war Italien in der Pause eigentlich mit dem 2-0 jetzt ergebnistechnisch relativ gut bedient und dann ist es komplett gekippt. Dann haben die Italiener das Kommando übernommen, da werden wir nachher noch mit Uli darüber sprechen, dass das auch ein bisschen vielleicht an den Engländern lag. Ja und dann fällt das 1-2 und dann kommt am Ende, ich glaube, 14 Minuten vor Schluss noch die gelb-rote Karte gegen Jordan, ist der Druck logisch noch mal größer geworden. Also es hat nicht viel gefehlt und die Italiener hätten noch einen Punkt geholt.
Und was war da bei England los, Uli?
Das selbe wie immer nach einer ordentlichen ersten Hälfte. Die war jetzt auch nicht komplett überzeugend, dass die einem die Sterne vom Himmel runtergespielt hätten. So nicht, aber es war okay. Es war effizient eben nach Standard-Situation und dann im zweiten Durchgang wird das oft eine seltsame Passivität, die dann Gegner dazu einlädt, nochmal zu kommen, wenn sie nicht früh zumachen. Das war auch so ähnlich im nächsten Länderspiel gegen die Ukraine, nur dass die halt qualitativ überhaupt nicht in der Lage waren, nochmal wirklich nachzulegen. Aber das ist leider ganz oft so bei den Engländern, dass die dann irgendwann gemütlich werden oder vielleicht sogar auch per Anordnung gemütlich werden. Das kann ich nicht nachvollziehen, aber das ist so gewesen, dass England dann Italien wieder stark gemacht hat. Ich glaube, das kann man genau nur so sagen. Das ist gar nicht aktiv von den Italiener auszusehen, sondern so muss es gewesen sein.
Jetzt ist es ja alles Teil der Qualifikation für die Europameisterschaft. Also es hat durchaus seinen Wert und es war natürlich allein dadurch, dass Italien und England in einer Gruppe gelandet sind, hatte das ja schon eine gewisse Brisanz. Christian, wie wurde das denn jetzt in Italien aufgenommen, dieses 1 zu 2, dem ja dann immerhin danach dann auch ein Sieg gefolgt ist im zweiten Spiel?
Ja, also die erste Hälfte war logisch aus italienischer Sicht ziemlich kritisch aufgenommen, was auch nachvollziehbar war. Ich bin auch völlig bei Uli, es ist jetzt nicht so, als ob die Engländer die Italiener in der ersten Hälfte an die Wand gespielt hätten. Aber was schon auffällig war, also man schien es wieder auf sein 4-3-3 zurück, was Italien ja auch, wer sich noch erinnert, bei der EM sehr stark gemacht hat, auch die Phase davor, hat auch ziemlich viele Namen, die auch damals bei der EM prägend waren, also zum Beispiel das Mittelfeld war genau diese Dreier-Besetzung, Giorginio Verratti-Barella. Das hat sich in Phasen auch in Hälfte 1 mit Ball ganz nett ansehen lassen, was aber überhaupt nicht gepasst hat in der ersten Hälfte, war so die Absicherung. Weil Jasmin Azolla wieder zurück ist, eine sehr schöne, also mehr als eine Randnotiz finde ich erstens schön, dass er wieder da ist und b. auch, dass es wirkt so wieder, als wäre er wieder auf dem Weg zurück der Alte zu werden. Hat sich ja bei der EM die Achilles-Szene gerissen und danach ewig gebraucht. Also dieses sehr linkslastige Offensivspiel Italiener, wo es Binazolla extrem hoch anschiebt und dementsprechend logischerweise auch Raum hinter sich lässt, das haben die Engländer sehr oft ausgenutzt. Also da hat die Abstimmung nicht gepasst. Verratti ist nicht eine Verratti-Sache allein, aber Verratti war halt auf dieser halblinken Position. Atxerbi und Toloi, muss man dazu sagen, ist jetzt alles andere als die 1a-Besetzung in der Innenverteidigung. Also die Abstände haben nicht gepasst und da hatten die Engländer echt viel Spaß. Gerade Kane hat sich da immer wieder auf rechts fallen lassen, hat Leute rausgezogen, Platz geschaffen. Also das hat überhaupt nicht gepasst und das aber haben die Italiener wirklich in der zweiten Hälfte angepasst. Ich bin bei Uli, die Engländer haben sie wieder rein geholt, aber ich bin schon auch immer der Meinung, dass dann schon auch was aktiv von Italiener ausgegangen ist. Das Pressing war viel, viel, viel besser. Sie haben die Engländer wieder viel höher angelaufen, haben sie dadurch zu Fehlern gezwungen, hatten viele hohe Ballgewinne und dann hat sich das Geschehen wirklich sehr viel in der englischen Hälfte abgespielt und was auch noch positiver aus italienischer Sicht war, obwohl dann noch so Leute wie Saka und so auf dem Platz waren, die Engländer hatten eigentlich, wenn ich mich recht erinnere, keinen wirklichen gefährlichen oder im Ansatz gefährlichen Konter. Also da hat die Absicherung gut gepasst. Also die zweite Hälfte ist definitiv das, worauf die Italiener aufbauen.
Das sollte gar nicht negativ den Italienern gegenüber klingen, sollte einfach, glaube ich, nur noch mal rausstellen, verdeutlichen, dass England ein Problem hat und das steht an der Seitenlinie.
Uli, ist es deine alte Gareth Southgate-Kritik, dass man eben so selten über 90 Minuten eigentlich eine überzeugende Leistung hinbekommt?
Ja, zum einen und zum anderen. Ich finde, es ist ja erstaunlich, wenn man sich die Einzelspieler anschaut, dann sind das ja größtenteils Spieler, die von außerordentlich guten Coaches kommen, also sprich aus top Mannschaften und die viel mit Automatismen machen. Man sieht manchmal, beispielsweise beim Kontern nach Balleroberung, dass zwei, drei Spieler in einen direkten Formationsflug gehen und trotzdem kommt dann der Ball am Ende nicht, weil es nicht vorgesehen ist in diesem System. Und das ist aus meiner Sicht ein deutlicher Vorwurf, den ich jetzt über Jahre erkenne bei Southgate, dass er nicht mit dem arbeitet, was die Spieler aus den Vereinen mitbekommen, sondern das ist so ein, lass uns halt mal schauen, was passiert. Und das sieht man England an, dass die einfach nicht optimal gecoacht sind. Es geht nie über den Automatismen, auch ja nicht bei den Turnieren. Wenn wir ehrlich sind, dann sind die Resultate auch vielleicht bei dieser WM okay gewesen und der Rest ist ja auch im Narrativ komplett gleich. Elfmeterschmerz und leere Hände. Und das hat Gründe, weil ich behaupte nach wie vor, wenn man mit diesem Kader, der jetzt auch zwei Glanzlichter wieder hervorgebracht hat, auf die man dann bauen kann, wenn man mit diesem Kader, der jetzt langsam auch dann im Übrigen deutlich in die Blüte oder darüber hinausgeht, so wie er zusammen ist jetzt schon seit Jahren, dann muss man irgendwann mal schaffen, dass die zusammen Fußball spielen und nicht nur Standardtore machen, um in den Turnieren mal mindestens ins Viertelfinale zu kommen. Aber – und das ist das Positive – also neben Harry Kane, der jetzt Rekord-Torschütze ist der Länderspielgeschichte Englands, seitdem Italien spielt und dann hat er gegen Ukraine sogar noch mal einen draufgelegt, aber Bukayo Saka und Jude Bellingham, beide 19, zeigen, sie sind die Zukunft dieses Landes.
Das sind die Glanzlichter, die du angesprochen hast?
Das sind die Glanzlichter, die man glaube ich schon noch mal herausheben muss, beide in ausgezeichneter Form, beide scheinen ein ganz, ganz, ganz spezielles Talent zu haben und auch eine ähnlich starke Persönlichkeit. Das sieht man inzwischen in jedem England-Länderspiel, dass das die beiden sind, die ziehen.
Und wie ist der Blick in Italien auf das Nationalteam? Ich habe ja schon angesprochen, man hat natürlich so eine kleine Hypothek und wir hatten das Thema ja auch neulich hier schon mal in der Ligatur.
Also wir müssen eine Sache noch ansprechen, die passt dann auch ganz gut so zum Blick drauf. Bei den Italienern hat ein Mittelstürmer gespielt, den glaube ich bis vor dem Spiel in Europa relativ wenig Menschen gekannt haben. Das kommt daher, dass der Herr aus Argentinien kommt, Matteo Retegi. Den hat mein Schini da gefischt. Er hat gesagt, mittelstürmermäßig schaut es bei uns echt sehr mau aus. Der hat den doppelten Pass, hat mit ihm gesprochen und hat ihn überzeugt, er geht zu Werder Bremen. Ja, mein Schini hat das auch ganz offen angesprochen. Er hat gesagt, hey, schaut es euch an, wir haben da große Probleme und diese Möglichkeit bestand. Er hat gemeint, er war auch überrascht, dass Retegi zugesagt hat, weil der jetzt schon auch in Argentinien liefert. Ist von Boca, ist ausgeliehen, gerade an Tigres. Und wenn man sich jetzt anschaut, ersten zwei Spiele in beiden getroffen. Gut, das zweite gegen Malta muss man jetzt vielleicht nicht so hoch hängen, aber wenn ich in meinem ersten Profi-Spiel außerhalb von Südamerika, weil er hatte wirklich noch nie europäischen Boden fußballerisch betreten, dann gleich gegen England treffe, würde ich mal sagen, ist das nicht die schlechteste Visitenkarte und zeigt auch wieder, dass man Chini da schon ein Auge dafür hat, auch Leute irgendwie zu finden. Dementsprechend ist das ein großes Thema, weil logischerweise die Frage ist, ja, der hat halt wirklich gar keinen Bezug zu Italien. Wenn wir uns zum Beispiel anschauen, die Jorginhos, die Tolloys, die jetzt zum Beispiel auch drauf standen oder auch Thiago Motta vor ein paar Jahren, die wurden jetzt zu großen Teilen fußballerisch in Italien sozialisiert. Also die haben sehr große Phasen ihrer Karriere auch in Italien verbracht. Bei Retegi ist es jetzt sozusagen eine neue Dimension. Also der hat wirklich bis jetzt gar keinen Bezug dazu, aber er hat den Pass. Mein Chini sagt, ich brauche ihn und dementsprechend hat er ihn geholt. Also das nur mal als kleine Info, aber ich glaube, der Name hat den wenigsten was gesagt. Aber es zeigt eben, dass mein Chini wirklich alles versucht, um sozusagen Nachschub zu organisieren. Retegi ist jetzt ein spezielles Beispiel, aber mein Chini probiert auch alles, um Jugend reinzubringen. Also es erinnern sich vielleicht noch ein paar. Mein Chini hat Sanjolo vor einigen Jahren berufen in die Nationalmannschaft, da hatte der noch keine Profiminute für die Roma gespielt, weil er gesagt hat, ich sehe da was in ihm und er kriegt mein Vertrauen. Gnonto, glaube ich, war bis vor dem letzten Saison auch den wenigsten Begriff, den hat er reingeschmissen. Jetzt ist er Schampfspieler bei Leeds in der Premier League. Also mein Chini hat da ein Auge dafür, gibt den Jungen auch Vertrauen und das beste Beispiel ist momentan, der sagt vielleicht noch dem wenigsten was, Pafundi, ein junger Kreativer von Udinese, der ist 17. Mein Chini sagt, er ist ein riesen Talent, aber der gute Junge hat bei Udinese bisher acht Minuten gespielt. So, aber mein Chini sagt, ich werde den immer einberufen, weil ich in dem grosses Talent sehe, ich werde ihn fördern und damit hält auch so ein bisschen der Liga den Spiegel vor, sag, hey, kommt mal in die Pötte, lasst die Junge mal spielen. Ich habe es euch vorgemacht, es gibt einige Beispiele, die können Fußball spielen, aber wir müssen sie halt Fußball spielen lassen und deswegen kam jetzt vor dem England-Spiel, ich finde echt der sehr schöne Satz von mein Chini hat gemeint, wenn ich die Nominierungen aufschreibe, der erste Name ist Bafundi, dann kommen alle anderen. Also ich finde mein Chini ist deshalb auch noch genau der richtige Mann für die Thalener, weil er wirklich da das Auge dafür hat und versucht da so ein bisschen auch eine Philosophiewechsel reinzubringen. Scalvini, ganz junger Mann von Atalanta, hat jetzt gegen Malta von Anfang an gespielt, also er geht da voran und ich glaube, das ist genau das, was die Thalener brauchen.
Tja, da sieht man mal, dass es auch vom Nationaltrainer aus gehen kann, so ein Wandel und gleichzeitig wird wahrscheinlich David müde lächeln, wenn man nach Argentinien gehen muss, um irgendwie Stürmer zu finden, denn diese Probleme hat Frankreich nicht, David. Ich weiß nicht, inwiefern du noch über dieses Nationalteam sprechen möchtest?
Bei Stürmern nicht, aber tatsächlich hatte ich mir im Vorfeld überlegt, auch um sozusagen den Absprung von unserer Ligatour in den Nationalteams zu machen, über Außenverteidiger zu sprechen. Da muss Frankreich suchen. Da sucht Frankreich nicht mal den super Außenverteidiger, eigentlich suchen sie überhaupt mal den Außenverteidiger. Wir erinnern uns, Deschamps hatte bei der WM sogar Mark Hamawinga als Außenverteidiger ausprobiert. Im Grunde haben sie aktuell mit Teohan Nes einen echten Außenverteidiger, der hat aber gegen Irland jetzt auch irgendwie enttäuscht. Und es gab jetzt gerade die Tage von Ligipta einen ausführlichen Artikel dazu, wo sie sich mal beschäftigt haben, indem sie auch Ausbilder in Clubs gefragt haben, woher kommt das denn eigentlich. Und das fand ich ganz spannend, weil da verschiedene Leute gesagt haben, ja, es sei tatsächlich immer noch so, dass sehr, sehr viele Jugendliche erst auf anderen Posten ausgebildet werden und die Clubs sich dann sagen, naja, die können wir ja später noch zum Außenverteidiger umschulen. Die Innenverteidiger können wir dann rausziehen und die offensiveren Leute können wir irgendwie noch zurückziehen und so. Und das habe eben auch damit zu tun, dass sehr, sehr viele Clubs den Frankreichs Sicherheitsausbildungsclubs sehen und damit auch Geld generieren müssen und nach wie vor im Mittelfeld und Stürmer die Kamantore verkaufen. Und wenn du da mal gedanklich das durchgehst, was du da so hättest als Nationaltrainer, auf links hast du da fast gar nichts. Du hast noch einen Fernand Mondi bei Real, der ist jetzt verletzt, aber ich glaube, der ist da auch nicht Stammspieler. Du hast einen Dignier, der ist schon 29, der war jetzt zwar bei der WM nicht dabei, ob der noch mal Lust hat, zurückzukommen, ist eh eine andere Frage. Und dann bist du schon bei genau dem, und da habe ich eben gerade so aufmerksam zugehört dann, da ist, glaube ich, der Jean auch anders als man schien. Du hättest einen jungen Adrien Truffert bei Rennes oder einen jungen Merlin bei Nantes, der jetzt auch verletzt ist. Das mag irgendwas für die Zukunft sein, aber das ist jetzt nichts, wo der Jean, glaube ich, sagt, die schmeiße ich jetzt mal da rein als somit ohne Champions-League-Erfahrung. Und auf rechts, ja, hast du einen Disasi von Marco, du hast einen Klaus, der auch schon 30 ist, bei Marseille. Und dann geht es auch schon wieder in die Jury-Rige, Sima Khan und zwei Außenverteidiger bei Lyon, Malo Guistot, der ist jetzt an Chelsea gegangen. Ja, also da könnte irgendwie bei Jüngeren was gehen, aber vielleicht so später irgendwann. Und wenn du dann halt im Vergleich dazu, zum Beispiel, mal nur mal nur nur schaust, was du an Innenverteidigern gerade in der Warteschlange hast.
Eben, ey, mach doch einfach die Büffel-Verteidigung, hat er auch dort schon gemacht.
Also da haben sich jetzt Konaté und Upo Mekano etabliert, übers Länderspiel-Wochenende. Jetzt ja auch beide nicht so alt, 23, 24. Und da im Hintergrund, du hättest einen Badia Schiel von Chelsea, du hättest einen Wesley Fofana von Chelsea, du hättest William Saliba von Arsenal, Lucas Hernandez, ein Dika und so weiter und so weiter. Ja, also Außenverteidiger immer noch eine Problemstelle. Trotzdem, Deschamps, Doing Deschamps-Things, zwei Spiele, ein glorreicher Sieg gegen Holland und ein maues-plätschernes Spielchen gegen Irland, wo dann Pavard sich nach vorne gezeigt hat mit einem WM-Agentinien-Gedächtnisschuss.
Ach echt? Ach, habe ich gar nicht gesehen.
Ja, ja, so ein richtiger Klopper wieder. Der hat ja anscheinend…
Hat es mal wieder funktioniert, weil bei Bayern versuchte er dieses Tor zu kopieren, seitdem er dieses Tor gemacht hat.
Genau. Ich glaube, er hat 16 Tore in seiner gesamten Spielerlaufbahn als Profi gemacht. Aber davon anscheinend… Ich glaube, bei Bayern waren auch so ein paar Kuriosere dabei, oder? Immerhin. Also wenn er trifft, dann doch…
Ja, aber diesen Schuss, den er da immer macht, vom rechten Strafraum-Eck, der wird halt in der Regel geblockt. Also allein gegen Gladbach, das weiß ich noch, Gladbach war durch das Spiel, wo angeblich ja ein Sommer den Punkt gehalten hat für Gladbach, lag aber auch daran, dass die aus jeder Situation geschossen haben und irgendwie zwölf der Schüsse waren geblockt. Da war Pavard auch mit dabei. Fünfmal hat er es da probiert. Das war ein Fest. Aber gut, wir wählen jetzt nicht hier in die Bundesliga, da wirkt mir direkt wieder schlecht. Lasst uns bei internationalem Fußball bleiben. Also das war aber sehr, sehr dominant gegen Liederland. Das muss man noch mal dazu sagen. Also schon nach 21 Minuten mit 3 zu 0 geführt. Griezmann, Uwe Meccano und Mbappé haben da getroffen. Und generell steht ja das französische Nationalteam ganz fantastisch da. Also man stand im WM-Finale, hat das nur mit viel Pech verloren. Das hätte auch anders ausgehen können, ist da auch zurückgekommen, weil du jetzt so leichte Kritik an Dich schon hast durchklingen lassen. Stehst du damit auch verloren im Posten mit dieser Kritik?
Nein, ich meinte das weniger als Kritik, sondern mehr so als es ist nach wie vor die Nationalmannschaft, die wir kennen, mit wow, sie kann unglaubliche Dinge und dann quält sie sich so gegen Irland rum. Ansonsten klar, die Evolution ist eingeleitet, das sieht schon alles sehr gefährlich aus. Loris und Varane haben sich zurückgezogen, Giroud ist auch schon 38, stattdessen kommt jetzt Koloumo Ani richtig zum Vorschein. Kamawinga durfte sich zeigen, der wird sich jetzt wohl einen Zweikampf liefern mit Choua Meni. Im Mittelfeld ist er jetzt auch nicht so die schlechteste Option, so ein Zweikampf zwischen Choua Meni und Kamawinga, während du auf der anderen Seite dann noch Rabiot und Grießmann hast. Dann könnten ja vielleicht Pogba und Kante auch nochmal zurückkommen. Und dann hat Menion, wissen ja Ligatour-Menschen auch, dass der Talent hat. Der hat auch eine unglaubliche Parade gegen Irland hingelegt in der letzten Minute.
Sorry, aber ich muss dazwischen gehen. Es sind nicht die Ligatour-Menschen, es sind natürlich die Ligatouristen. Das versteht auch jede Hörerin und jeder Hörer.
Genau. Also, sofern alles in Ordnung. Der Aufreger war dann die Frage, wer wird Kapitän.
Und wer ist es geworden? Das ist natürlich überraschend. Ich hab versucht interessiert zu klingen, aber bei mir ist sowas immer so total egal. Das soll sie doch machen. Aber ich verstehe, warum das ein Thema ist. Ich meine, in Deutschland ist ja auch jeder Furz ein Thema.
Darf ich mal ganz kurz rein, wenn Roberto Mancini die letzten Minuten gehört hatte und all diese Namen und ich würde mal sagen, Roberto Mancini ist nicht der einzige Nationaltrainer, in dem es so geht, dann würde ich mal sagen, dass sind wir da bei Frankreich in einem krassen Luxusdiskussion. Denn wenn Theo Hernandez das Problem ist, also ich glaube, das Problem hätten sehr viele Nationaltrainer sehr gerne.
Ja, das ist es ja. Die Frage ist jetzt aber natürlich, was würde Luis de la Fuente sagen, wenn er das gehört hätte? Denn bei Spanien, die wir hier ja auch noch mit dabei haben, mit Alex, da ließ jetzt ein bisschen anders in der Qualifikation, vor allem in Schottland.
Ja, ich muss sagen, wenn man die Namen so durchgeht, die sind nicht ganz so illuster wie bei Frankreich. Es gibt ein paar alte Bekannte, die man zwar kennt, aber irgendwie liest sich das nicht ganz so nach der Qualität, die einem entgegenspringt, wenn man bei Frankreich so die Namen durchgeht.
Aber was hat sich denn da eigentlich verändert? Ist das nicht eigentlich irre? Weil Spanien war ja auch mal das Vorzeigeland für eine durchgehende Philosophie. Ich meine, Spanien war so erfolgreich in seinen Strukturen, dass die Schweiz ja zu einer kompletten Kopie von Spanien, zur Raubkopie von Spanien liefert, dann nicht ganz so erfolgreich. Aber dieses eben eine Philosophie durchziehen von der Jugend bis ins Nationalteam, dann eben auch einen Kern in der Nationalmannschaft zu haben. Schon interessant, dass wir jetzt quasi – Frankreich ist da heiße Scheiß und bei England haben wir jetzt zwei neue Glanzlichter. Und Mancini muss zwar ein bisschen experimentieren, aber tut das jetzt ja auch zumindest.
Und ich würde auch sagen, da ist schon auch ein bisschen was da, mit dem man arbeiten kann.
Genau, also das wollte ich eben damit sagen. Und wenn ich jetzt mir Spanien angucke, Alex, also ich habe natürlich dieses 0 zu 2 in Schottland mitbekommen. Ich habe mir dann gleich die Statistiken angeguckt, weil ich mir dachte, naja gut, die werden schon 33 zu 5 Schüsse gehabt haben und dann passiert es halt dann. Und dann sehe ich, nee, 8 Schüsse Spanien, 9 Schüsse Schottland, natürlich 75 Prozent Ballwiese Spanien, alles klar, logisch, überrascht mich jetzt nicht. Aber das sieht dann schon gravierender aus, ohne dass ich jetzt das Spiel gesehen habe.
Ja, also schlechter Start. Was hat sich geändert? Ja, logisch, die Trainerposition hat sich geändert. Luis Enrique ist nach der WM nicht mehr da. Vertrag wurde nicht verlängert. Der lief ja tatsächlich just nach der WM aus. Wurde ja so gelegt, dass man sich nach der WM zusammensetzt. Wurde dann nicht verlängert und Luis de la Fuente ist sein Nachfolger. Der war vorher U21-Trainer. Also da ein klarer Cut. Da war man sehr, sehr unzufrieden mit dem Abschneiden bei der WM, wo Spanien ja enorm enttäuscht hat in der deutschen Gruppe, dann mit einem 7-1 losgelegt und danach kam sie irgendwie dann doch nicht mehr aus den Startlöchern. Von daher hat man ein bisschen kalte Füße bekommen beim spanischen Verband, denn Luis Enrique war vorher schon immer sehr, sehr angreifbar durch die Medien, war sehr teilweise sehr unbeliebt, vor allem in den Medien immer wieder aus verschiedensten Gründen. Er ist halt ein sehr streitbarer Typ und dann dachte man sich bei der WM, okay, das hat jetzt doch nicht so geklappt, wie er wünscht, komm wir machen einen Neustart und dieser Neustart ging jetzt eben schon im zweiten Spiel mächtig in die Hose. Da hat Spanien jetzt nicht unbedingt so super schlecht gespielt, aber eben auch sehr, sehr wieder sehr, sehr, sehr durchschnittlich und da das ist so der Übergang zum Team, über das wir sprechen wollen. Dieses Team ist, glaube ich, wirklich ein durchschnittliches Team und das wird sich, fürchte ich, in den nächsten Monaten vielleicht Jahren mehr und mehr auch auf dem Platz darlegen.
Aber darf ich da mal schnell was fragen? Ich glaube auch, mitbekommen bei Nils Kern, deinem Podcastpartner, dass der Luis Enrique jetzt als nicht so richtig gut evaluiert hat. Ich habe eigentlich gefunden, wann immer ich die gesehen habe, die wirkten außerordentlich gut trainiert. Eines der wenigen internationalen Teams bei der WM, wo ich mir dachte, oh schau mal, da sind ja totale Abläufe da beispielsweise. Also klar, der Typ ist mit Twitch und so, das alles kann man darüber streiten, aber so als Trainer habe ich immer das Gefühl, das ist gar kein so schlechter.
Ja, und die Fachpresse hat das auch so gesehen, aber die mediale Meinung in Spanien im Durchschnitt war eben eher, da hoffen wir uns mehr und er ist eben streitbar und er hat nicht jeden auf seine Seite gezogen, so will ich es jetzt mal nennen. Also zum einen, er hat natürlich diesen Barca-Background und hat seine Nationalmannschaft stark um den Barca-Core aufgebaut, also um den Kern Barceloners mit Busquets in der Schallzentrale, natürlich Gavi Petri, Ferran Torres war bei ihm gesetzt, Jordi Alba links, also allein diese Namen sind einfach der Kern des FC Barcelona und das hat jetzt Luis de la Fuente komplett geändert als ja fast schon erste Amtshandlung, denn interessanterweise bei der WM waren sieben Barca-Spieler dabei, also mit Abstand die meisten, ich glaube von Real Madrid war beispielsweise nur ein Spieler dabei, die haben einfach nicht so viel Spanier in der Startelf. Jetzt bei der EM-Quali zwei Barcelona-Spieler nur noch, also das ist schon ein klarer Cut. Petri war verletzt, sonst wären es drei gewesen, aber trotzdem, man merkt das schon, da gibt es einen klaren Cut und ja, ich fand auch, dass Spanien unter Luis Enrique am ehesten wie eine Vereinsmannschaft wirkte, das war bei der WM, wenn ich mich zurück erinnere, auch aus der Fachpresse dann die Meinung, vor allem natürlich nach diesem rauschhaften 7-1, aber danach haben sie halt einfach enttäuscht, haben ja, sind früh ausgeschieden gegen Marokko, waren planlos gegen Marokko im Angriff, das muss man auch zugeben und so hat man sich dann getrennt, ob es jetzt Fluch oder Segen ist, oder ob es eine gute Entscheidung ist oder eine schlechte, wird einfach die EM-Quali zeigen und die Nations League.
Gleichzeitig ist es ja aber so, also man ist in einer Gruppe, mit Schottland offensichtlicherweise, mit Norwegen, die hat man schon besiegt, Georgien und Zypern. Also müsste man jetzt quasi allein von der Konstellation her, auch wenn es natürlich ärgerlich ist, in Schottland zu gewinnen, aber das kann ja mal passieren. Es ist ja auch extrem schwierig für De La Fuente, wenn er quasi jetzt nach zwei Spielen dann schon so hart kritisiert wird. Ist die Stimmung auch so, also weil das klang jetzt alles schon relativ, als ob da schon große Diskussionen schon wieder zu hören wären in Spanien. Ist das jetzt auch so, oder ist da mein Eindruck einfach falsch?
Nee, das ist nicht so. Ich glaube, er bekommt natürlich die Zeit und allein, dass er nicht so ein großer Name ist, dadurch ist auch, glaube ich, der Druck nicht so groß, vor allem weil Spanien ja zuletzt enttäuscht hat. Also die Stimmung ist ja jetzt eh nicht so euphorisch grundsätzlich nach diesem durchaus blamablen WM aus. Das kann man, glaube ich, schon sagen, mit einem Sieg in vier Spielen. Das ist einfach ein sehr, sehr schwaches Abschneiden sportlich gesehen. Von daher bekommt er da, glaube ich, schon ein bisschen mehr Zeit. Es ist jetzt ja auch nur EM-Qualifikation. Es ist jetzt auch kein großes Turnier. Nicht jeder ist so euphorisch, ob dieser EM-Quali weder in Deutschland noch in Spanien noch sonst wo, denke ich. Ich habe heute früh vor der Podcastaufnahme auch noch mal die Marker gecheckt. Da siehst du jetzt schon keine Überschriften mehr, keine Headlines, keinen Artikel mehr über die Nationalmannschaft, was ja auch kurios ist. Zwei Tage nach einer Niederlage. Aber grundsätzlich das Bild, das die Nationalmannschaft in der Wirkung, wie ich finde, abgibt, ist eher so ein zurück zum Mediokre in Spanien. Das ist meine Befürchtung. Das sind auch einfach – der Pool der Spieler ist auch nicht mehr so glanzvoll. Das muss man auch einfach konstatieren. Und was natürlich auffällt bei Luis de la Fuente sind, dass er viele Namen nominiert hat, die unter Luis Enrique gar keine Rolle spielten, die nie auch nur eingeladen wurden, die nie eine Chance bekamen, wo es da in der Öffentlichkeit und in den Medien gegrummel gab, warum Luis Enrique quasi Spieler, die nicht seine Spieler sind, vermeintlich, warum er denen nie eine Chance gibt. Obwohl sie in La Liga überzeugen, aber in der Regel eben nicht bei Barcelona, Real Madrid oder Atletico, sondern bei durchschnittlichen Teams, bei kleineren Teams. Und denen hat er jahrelang nie eine Chance gegeben. Und das macht Luis de la Fuente jetzt schon. Also er setzt mehr auf dieses – ich nenne es mal – Liga-Leistungsprinzip, führt aber natürlich dazu, wenn du viele Spieler hast von – ich übertreibe jetzt mal – von Espanyol, von Osasuna, von Celta Vigo, also einfach sehr, sehr durchschnittlichen Teams, dass eben auch deine Nationalmannschaft vielleicht so ein bisschen vom Niveau her eher Richtung Durchschnitt geht.
Das war jetzt wirklich mal interessant, mal ein bisschen auf die Nationalteams zu gucken, was wir sonst hier in der Ligatur ja immer aussperren bzw. generell im Rasenfunk, denn irgendwann möchte ich auch mal ein freies Wochenende haben. Deswegen habe ich mir auch den Luxus herausgenommen, keines von den Spielen, über das wir hier gesehen haben, auch nur im Ansatz gesehen zu haben. Ich weiß nur, dass McTominay die zwei Tore gegen Spanien gemacht hat. Das habe ich mitbekommen und dann habe ich Statistiken gesuchtet, wie so ein absoluter Weirdo, anstatt mir Highlights anzugucken.
Ich hätte noch eine Rausschmeißer-Anekdote aus dem Nationalmannschaftssegment.
Ja, gerne.
Weil bei Frankreich zum ersten Mal beide Brüder Thürammen nominiert waren. 25, 21 Jahre. Wir haben auch beide so ein paar Minütchen Einsatz in der Nachspielzeit bekommen. Der eine bei Erland, der andere bei Holland. Und das haben dann die Medien zum Anlass genommen, um noch mal da nachzuschauen, so wie sind sie denn ausgebildet worden. Wie lebt es sich denn so als Brüderpaar? Ist ja auch verrückt, wenn man sich das überlegt. Vater, Nationalspieler, Legende und beide Brüder jetzt im Nationalteam. Und dann kamen da so wunderschöne Anekdoten raus, dass also Vater Thüram beim Athletic Club Boulogne-Bilancourt, also wo die gespielt haben, sei ja öfter zum Training erschienen, aber aber immer versucht, sich unter seinem Hut zu verstecken. Aber die Leute hätten ihn trotzdem erkannt. Und Kev Frenz sei einmal ermahnt worden von seinen Jugendtrainer, dass er da in dem oder dem Spiel nicht genug gelaufen sei und hatte erwidert, naja es sei wohl viel, viel wichtiger, richtig zu stehen. Und beim nächsten Spiel ist aber trotzdem doppelt so viel gelaufen.
Hm, das habe ich früher auch mal gesagt.
Sag ich heute noch.
Ja, bei dir ist es wichtig, dass du sitzt, Uli. Beziehungsweise, wobei, ich weiß nicht, neulich habe ich wieder irgendwo gehört, wenn es besonders spannend wird, dann müssen Sportkommentatoren aufstehen, um diese Spannung zu kanalisieren. Aber das ist jetzt vielleicht ein anderes Thema. Da ging es auch um Handballkommentate, also komplett andere Sportart. Da möchte ich nicht, dass der Fußball vom Handball kommt.
Bei uns geht es, kann man das so nicht sagen.
Ihr legt euch hin, wenn es spannend wird.
Das ist schwierig im Stadion, weil der Hintermann, der findet es nicht so lustig, wenn du dann plötzlich aufstehst.
Ja, das habe ich auch schon mal gehört. Aber gut, das ist jetzt ein anderes Thema. Aber wenn du jetzt eh gerade schon am Sprechen bist, Uli, also wir haben jetzt viel über das Nationalteam gesprochen. Gibt es denn in der Liga, in der Premier League, gibt es da auch Themen, wo du sagen würdest, das ist jetzt noch wichtig zu besprechen, vielleicht auch mit Blick auf, dass es jetzt ja dann weitergeht nach der Länderspielpause?
Ja, ich habe lange überlegt, was ich mitbringen könnte. Ich versuche ja immer, dass ich nicht so ganz abgegriffene Themen nutze und dann habe ich mich für Tottenham entschieden.
Was ist denn da los? Was? Was?
Mir fällt jetzt nichts mit Antonio ein, deswegen muss ich das Contemporary anders machen. Wir wissen ja seit dem letzten Mal, dass wir gesprochen haben, dass er nicht mehr länger weitermachen wollte. Ich finde, der Verein hat sehr lange gezögert, um die Entscheidung zu treffen. Jetzt haben sie sie getroffen. Antonio konnte es nicht mehr trennen, soweit ist es jetzt noch nicht so neu. Was jetzt tatsächlich neu ist, ist, dass die Sperre Fabio Baratti – das ist ja sozusagen das Mastermind im Hintergrund, für den extra eine Stelle geschaffen worden ist bei Tottenham – noch vor 17 Stunden war es am Ende, bevor seine Sperre auch weltweit deklariert worden ist, die er bislang nur sich auf den italienischen Raum bezog, hat er noch ein Video aufgenommen, in dem er noch erzählt hat, ja keine Angst, wir kriegen hier alles hin. 5 Minuten lang ganz seltsames Stück. Und keinen Tag später kommt raus, dass die Sperre jetzt erst einmal weltweit gilt. Das heißt, er darf in den nächsten 20 Monaten gar nicht mehr arbeiten für Tottenham. Und jetzt hat man nicht nur keinen Trainer, sondern jetzt hat man auch keinen Director, sozusagen, und noch weniger Richtung. Das heißt, Daniel Levy, der ja eigentlich nur der Verhandler ist und sportlich gesehen – mal sagt man so, mal sagt man so – aber nicht jetzt total überzeugt hat mit den letzten Entscheidungen. Der muss jetzt einen neuen Trainer suchen und vielleicht sogar einen neuen Sportdirektor. Weil es ist immer noch nicht geklärt, kann dann am Ende Paratigy weitermachen? Ja, nein. Tottenham hat schon angekündigt, sie werden sämtliche Einsprüche vornehmen, die es vorzunehmen gilt. Aber bis dahin sind die erst einmal so gesehen eingefroren, was auch immer das bedeutet, dass er nicht verhandeln darf. Man kann ja theoretisch aus dem Hintergrund Dinge machen, aber zumindest vorne rum darf der nicht arbeiten. Also ganz schönes Chaos bei Tottenham, mal wieder.
Und das muss man jetzt noch kurz dazu sagen. Also das ist Paratigy und der wurde gesperrt wegen der Dinge, die er bei Juwel getan hat. Deswegen war er auch zuerst für Italien gesperrt.
Ganz genau. Da ist das ganze Board auch schon zurückgetreten. Paratigy war schon gar nicht mehr da. Deswegen ist er dann ja nicht mehr zurückgetreten und es ging darum, dass sie sich Vorteile bei Transfers verschafft haben. Das ist so der gesammelte Überbegriff. Also sprich, sie haben in Bilanzen rumgeschönt etc. Das ist der Vorwurf. Das ist ja bislang auch noch nicht weiter nachgewiesen, aber das ist der Vorwurf der Untersuchung und bis dahin bis auf weiteres gesperrt.
Also das sieht man die Staatsanwaltschaft in Turin, die er das Ganze in Gang gebracht hat. Die Untersuchung in Italien läuft unter dem Codenamen Prisma. Also das sieht man, was tiefe Auswirkungen hat. Also es ist ja eine reguläre Staatsanwaltschaft, da sind wir ja weg vom Sportgerichtsbarkeit.
Aber das ist wieder diese Bilanzfälschung, bzw. nicht Bilanzfälschung, sondern Verschönung.
Es gibt ja mehrere Stränge, die da von der Staatsanwaltschaft verfolgt werden. Auch für Juve ist das Ding ja noch lange nicht durch, da können auch noch andere Aspekte kommen. Und eben genau wie Uli es gesagt hat, bisher auch zum Beispiel die Agnellis, die Netwets, die alle zurückgetreten sind, dürfen jetzt erstmal keine andere Funktion in Italien ausüben. Nur bis jetzt eben war das auf Italien gemünzt. In Italien war sogar dann oft die Rede vom System Paratici. Also diese ganzen Vorwürfe, die da bei Juve im Raum stehen, da schien Paratici eine zentrale Rolle gehabt zu haben. Und jetzt sieht man, dass dann so eine Ermittlung auch dazu führen kann, dass es im Moment eben die Sperre dann erstmal weltweit gilt. Und dann auch ein Verein in einem komplett anderen Land jetzt, wie Uli es ja beschrieben hat, durchaus ein Problem hat.
Na gut, weil man sich aber auch jemanden holt, der damals involviert war. Um noch mal kurz alle Hörerinnen und Hörer ins Boot zu holen, bei den bilancieren Vorwürfen gegen Juve – und deswegen ist es auch ein Staatsanwaltschaftsthema, weil wir sprechen hier über Wirtschaftsbilanzen von Unternehmen – ging es eben darum, dass man gegenseitige Transfers gemacht hat mit Spielern, mit anderen Vereinen und dabei jeweils eine Ablösesumme angesetzt hat, die höher war als marktüblich. Und das hat den folgenden Vorteil, die Ablöse. Man hat einmal quasi einen großen Zugang, weil man hat hier einen Spieler für, sagen wir mal, 90 Millionen verkauft. Das habe ich jetzt schon in meiner Bilanz stehen. Und den Spieler, den ich aber gekauft habe für 90 Millionen oder 80 Millionen, den schreibe ich über die Vertragslaufzeit ab. Das heißt, bilanziell ist damit meine Bilanz besser geworden, weil die künftigen Ausgaben werden verteilt über die Jahre und die einmalige Einnahme ist hoch. Und das soll Juwe gemacht haben und das ist eben dann im Bereich der Wirtschaftskriminalität.
Genau, also da kann man, da können wir eine eigene Sendung darüber machen, denn der Punkt ist, wie du es angesprochen hast, da für so ein System brauchst du auch immer einen zweiten Verein. Also den kann nicht einer alleine machen.
Es war nicht nur Juwe, genau, das muss man wirklich sagen.
Und das andere Thema ist logischerweise auch, das ist ja auch darauf fußt die Juwe-Verteidigung jetzt, die sagt, ja bitte leg mir mal hin, wie viel ist dann ein Profi-Fußballer-Wert? Also die Summen sind jetzt 10 Millionen realistisch oder sind es 20 dann nicht mehr oder 12 schon. Also das ist schon ein sehr spezielles Thema, was eben auch in Italien zeigt, da verwischt sich so ein bisschen Wirtschaftskriminalität mit Sport, sag ich mal, sportlichen Aspekten. Dementsprechend, das wird uns eh noch länger beteiligen.
Ich finde aber, Sport und Wirtschaft sollte man nicht miteinander.
Aber Uli, ich verstehe gar nicht, wo das Problem ist. Also Patrici ist jetzt weltweit gestartet, aber man kann doch Nagelsmann, kann man doch auch so verpflichten.
Genau, deswegen habe ich ja nicht ganz uneigennützlich immer nachgefragt, um das schon mal einschätzen zu können, falls das passiert. Also Patrici soll ja Luis Enrique deutlich vorgeschlagen haben. Das ist jetzt die Frage, nachdem er ja eingefroren ist, ob das dann noch passiert oder nicht. Ich glaube, man könnte schon auch bei Julian Nagelsmann anrufen, hat man auch schon getan, im Übrigen auch bei Oliver Glasner. Ich glaube nur, was will man denen sagen und zeigen? Die Mannschaft ist ja mental derart ausgelaugt, weil es hat wenigstens in Sonnen mal einer gesagt, dass er es bedauert, dass er weg ist. Wenigstens. Mehr habe ich zumindest noch nicht vernommen. Ansonsten wirken die einfach platt und jetzt von vielen verschiedenen Ideen von vielen verschiedenen Trainern auch einfach ausgelutscht. Also die haben es mit Mourinho probiert, dann haben sie es mit Nuno Espirito Santo probiert, dann kommt Konte, dann waren zwischendrin noch ein paar Interimstrainer, die ran durften. Das Lied war immer das gleiche. Es war alles abhängig von Sonne und von Kane. Die sind jetzt dann langsam auf der falschen Seite der 30. Loris muss glaube ich inzwischen ausgetauscht werden, wenn man die Leistungen so sieht. Das heißt, außer des Stadions ist ja nichts da, mit dem man ernsthaft an die Top 6 angreifen kann. Nachdem Arsenal jetzt auch noch mal stärker geworden ist, ist das Fenster richtig zugeknallt, um selber mal Titel zu holen. Das müsste man jetzt irgendwie verkaufen nach draußen an den Trainer, der da kommen mag, dass man sagt, du kannst hier aufbauen und wir gehen wieder in den alten, in Tottenham-Modus rein, der da heißen könnte, wir bauen auf junge Spieler und versuchen, die Stufe vor der Stufe sozusagen zu sein. Aber ich sehe nicht, dass Julian Nagelsmann das machen muss, um es jetzt mal ganz hart zu formulieren. Ich glaube, der hat andere Optionen.
Erst mal ein bisschen weiter Gehalt beziehen für Netflix-Bingen.
Aber gut, er ist natürlich ein junger Mann, der arbeiten will, aber ich würde ihm auch sagen, jetzt wart doch mal ab, Meisterprämie ist noch drin und so.
Vielleicht ist so jemand wie Nagelsmann dann jemand, über den die FDP immer spricht. Die sagt ja wie hier, wir müssen noch mal das Arbeitslosengeld weiter streichen oder das Bürgergeld, wie auch immer man es jetzt nennen will, damit die Anreize größer sind zu arbeiten. Vielleicht denken die immer an Politik.
Ich finde, Politik hat im Sport nichts verloren.
Und in der Wirtschaft auch nicht.
Ja, und die FDP hat damit Politik auch gar nicht so viel zu tun, seien wir ehrlich. Aber was ist denn dann deine Prognose, wie es bei Tottenham weitergeht? So schwierig das jetzt ist, aber wir haben hier große Probleme. Wir haben es aber auch schon kommen sehen. Also niemanden wird das jetzt völlig unvorbereitet treffen. A, dass ein Hot-Tottenham-Trainer nicht glücklich wird. B, dass Antonio Conte jetzt doch entlassen wurde. Und C, wir alle wissen ja auch um diese Abhängigkeit von Kane und Sonnen. Also gefühlt hätte das jetzt auch gerade ein Segment von vor fünf Jahren sein können, nur halt mit anderen Namen. Wie ist deine Einschätzung, was bei Tottenham jetzt passiert in den nächsten Jahren?
Schwierig zu sagen, weil ich gar nicht weiß, wer die Entscheidungen trifft. Also du hast vollkommen recht mit dem, was du sagst. Es ist alles das Gleiche, nur dass sie natürlich jetzt da diesen millionenschweren Imperativ stehen haben in Form des Stadions, der sie natürlich auch zwingt zu handeln. Was wird passieren? Ich habe keine Ahnung. Die werden so schnell wie möglich versuchen, entweder Parati-C zu entfrieren oder nicht. Und ansonsten müssen sie ja sehr, sehr schnell handeln. Ich glaube, so werden sie es machen. Versuchen, das bisschen, was noch da ist, so schnell wie möglich wieder ins Laufen zu bringen, den nächsten überbezahlten Top-Trainer holen, um dann eins weiter zu gucken. Mir fehlt die Fantasie, was die tun könnten. Aus meiner Sicht müssten die jetzt einreißen und sagen, wir gehen zurück zu dem, was wir mal hatten. So sind sie auch unter Pochettino das letzte Mal stark geworden. Sie holen drei 24-Jährige, 25-Jährige, haben einen recht kreativen Marktblick. Der war ja ehrlicherweise jetzt auch zum Schluss nicht mehr kreativ, sondern es waren halt Leute, die bei Juve nicht funktioniert haben, die dann Paratici dahingeholt hat. Die haben dann auch fairerweise einigermaßen funktioniert, aber früher hatten sie ja mal die Berbertovs, als noch bevor der richtig stark war, die Bails aus Southampton. War jetzt auch kein Geheimnis, dass der was kann, aber so in die Richtung hat man es ja mal gemacht. Und das würde ich mir wünschen, das würde ich dem Verein auch wünschen. Ich weiß aber ehrlich gesagt – und ich glaube, die auch nicht – also die scheinen tatsächlich von dieser weltweiten Sperre überrascht zu sein. Der Club wirkt gerade so. Ich habe auch noch mal mit einem Beatwriter gesprochen, der Tottenham täglich begleitet. Der auch sagte, die scheinen so, als haben sie gedacht, ach, wenn dann wäre es ja jetzt schon eine weltweite Sperre. Wir machen jetzt einfach mal weiter.
Ach, irgendwie auch wohltuend zu hören, dass nicht nur der FC Bayern auf strategischer Ebene manchmal auch die einfachsten Dinge nicht zu sehen scheinen sollen, dass es auch in anderen Ligen passiert. Aber naja, das ist jetzt ein anderes Thema. Ich will es hier gar nicht weiter. Wir haben ja Nagelsmann den Namen schon fallen lassen. Das soll an der Stelle reichen. Also wir gucken uns an, was bei Tottenham passiert. Was gucken wir uns denn in La Liga an, Alex? Ich habe dich jetzt schon mehrmals so durchschnopfen hören. Ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt alles wegen Luis Enrique war oder woran liegt das?
Interessanterweise übrigens hat er vor zwei Tagen ein Interview gegeben, wo er klar gesagt hat, ich möchte in der Premier League arbeiten, dass das sein Ziel ist und dass er da zu einem Top-Punk will.
Das sagst du uns jetzt.
Ich bin ja jetzt erst dran. Nein, und dass er wirklich in der Premier League, dass das ein Ziel ist, ein Wunsch von ihm und dass aber nur wenige Vereine in Frage kämen, denn er möchte einen Verein trainieren mit Optionen, also im Sinne von, so interpretiere ich einfach mal, wo er Chancen hat, Titel zu gewinnen, wo er sicherlich einen ganz guten Kader vorfindet, den er vielleicht auch selbst verbessern kann. Also ein bisschen finanzielle Hilfe im Hintergrund und natürlich garantiert in der Champions League wieder spielen. Und das sind so die Wünsche und Hoffnungen, die er für seinen nächsten Job auf der Insel sich vorstellen kann. Und so viele Vereine gibt es da jetzt auch nicht, die irgendwie das erfüllen und gleichzeitig in England liegen. Von daher bin ich da mal gespannt, ob es da Richtung Tottenham vielleicht geht, vielleicht Richtung Chelsea, die aber möglicherweise die Champions League verpassen, aber ja vielleicht im Sommer einen neuen Trainer gebrauchen könnten. Also die Personale, Luis Enrique, die finde ich tatsächlich recht spannend in dem Zusammenhang mit Tottenham.
Ja, das ist wirklich interessant. Das Timing ist bestimmt nicht zufällig von so einem solchen Interview.
Das weiß ich nicht. Uli, weil du es vorhin angesprochen hast, vielleicht gibt es ja dann Twitch-Streams in der Zukunft vom Vereinsgelände Tottenhams oder von wo auch immer oder von der Stamford Bridge.
Das finde ich ja wirklich sehr spannend, muss ich sagen. Ich finde schon, dass der Typ was hat und dass das mal ein guter neuer Ansatz ist, das so zu machen. Und es braucht ja bei Tottenham einen einzigen, der spricht. Das hat ja Konter immer wieder gesagt, dass das anders gar nicht möglich ist, weil der Verein untereinander nicht kommuniziert. Deswegen warum denn nicht dieses Chaos auch bei Twitch mal verfolgen?
Kurzer Kontext übrigens.
Lieber bitte mal den Kontext, weil ich habe ihn mir gerade hier bei Ecosia googelt.
Luis Enrique hat bei der WM tatsächlich Twitch-Streams gestartet. Jeden, ich glaube, zweiten oder dritten Tag, exklusiv da. Er hat gesagt, er will eine ungefilterte Meinung. Man hat quasi die Medien sein lassen und hat sein Twitch-Stream angemacht und hat stundenlang, also wirklich so ein Stream ging teilweise eine Stunde oder länger, über alles Mögliche geredet, ungefiltert, sehr, sehr unterhaltsam. Also auch wirklich über alltägliche Sachen, aber natürlich auch über das Mannschaftsinnenleben. Also hat wirklich wie ein echter Twitch-Streamer Fragen der User beantwortet, die hier unten reingestellt wurden. Also wirklich, ich habe auch einige Streams gesehen. Sehr, sehr unterhaltsam, sehr, sehr erfrischend, sehr interessant. Aber man kann sich vorstellen, das kam in Spanien tatsächlich in den Medien auch nicht ganz so super an.
Aber an welchen großen deutschen Trainer erinnert uns das?
An Jürgen K.
Jürgen Klinsmann bei Hertha WC. Exakt Facebook Live mit einem Spieler. Und dann wird aber am Tag vor dem Spiel noch mal Leute müssen alle zusammenhalten. Und ja, das ist alles nicht so einfach. Wobei, ich mache mich jetzt lustig darüber. Eigentlich fand ich das ganz interessant.
Also bei Klinsmann habe ich es nicht mitbekommen, aber ich würde jetzt Klinsmann auch nicht so vom Typus her und auch von der Arbeit her nicht mit Luis Enrique vergleichen wollen. Ich glaube, der ist ein bisschen der serösere Coach und Mensch.
Wollen wir nochmal über die südkoreanische Nationalmannschaft reden? Würde mich tatsächlich echt interessieren. Also jetzt kein Witz.
Durchwachsener Start nach dem, was ich gelesen habe, aber nur überflogen die Artikel. Aber gut, geben wir Jürgen Klinsmann ein bisschen Zeit. Auch in Südkorea.
Sorry, ganz kurz noch. Die Personale, Luis Enrique, ist wirklich eine spannende. Da kann man ja auch einen kleinen Bogen zu Italien spannen. Er war ja vor einigen Jahren in Rom. Er kam ja von Barca dahin mit diesen ganzen Titeln im Gepäck und hat es da auch nicht einfach gehabt. Also jetzt muss man auch sagen, Rom ist auch ein spezielles Medienumfeld. Jetzt im Nachhinein haben ihn dann auch einige Tränen nachgeweint, weil sie gemeint haben, Fußball fachlich, da brauchen wir gar nicht drüber reden. Aber es war echt schwierig für ihn auch, in dieser schwierigen Fußball- und Medienstadt Rom zurechtzukommen. Deswegen, also ich würde es ihm gönnen, wenn er vielleicht im Ausland jetzt dann auch mal irgendwo unterkommt, wo er seine Fußball-Lehrer-Qualitäten dann wirklich auch zeigen kann.
Darf ich kurz korrigieren? Er war bei der Roma, bevor er bei Barca angestellt war. Rom war ein Fiasco, da wurde er früh entlassen, das ist korrekt. Aber quasi so zum richtigen Trainer, der er ist, wurde er bei Barca mit dem Gewinn des Trippels.
Aber Fiasco ist auch ein großes Wort. Dann ja, er wurde entlassen. Aber zum Beispiel, wenn du mit den De Rossis und vielen großen Spielern sprichst, die damals bei der Roma waren, die haben gemeint, wir haben es geliebt mit ihm. Also was er uns fußballerisch sozusagen gegeben hat, das war Wahnsinn. Nur wie gesagt, das war von Anfang an mit Clubführung auch medial schwierig und dementsprechend war das Ding dann bald mal vorbei. Aber wenn du auch mit großen Spielern redest, dann war denen von Anfang an klar, es war eigentlich extrem, was deren Qualität sozusagen auch in der täglichen Arbeit mitgebracht hat.
Ach so, jemanden würde ich so gerne mal in Deutschland sehen. Ich meine in der Bundesliga völlig utopisch, weil da ist nur ein Job irgendwie interessant für die und der ist jetzt gerade neu besetzt worden. Aber mal so als Nationalteam-Trainer hätte ich – naja gut. Aber das ist jetzt ein anderes Thema. Warum komme ich heute eigentlich die ganze Zeit? Wahrscheinlich fehlt mir die Bundesliga.
Ich glaube ja auch, dass das ist.
Ich bin selber schockiert von mir.
Psychologisch, analytisch würde ich das jetzt auch so sagen.
Ja, das könnte ja da mal die Hörerinnen und Hörer unter Mitmachung Rasenfunk.de machen im Forum. Das wird auch sicherlich passieren. Aber Alex, wir waren ja eigentlich bei der Frage, ob in der Liga noch irgendein Thema wichtig ist. Da gab es ein Klassikoo, der wurde geworden unter anderem. Ich weiß nicht, ob das noch was ist, über das du sprechen möchtest oder was ist wichtig?
Die Madridistas wollen glaube ich nicht, dass ich darüber spreche. Richtig, der Klassiker wurde ja von Barca gewonnen. De facto ist die Liga jetzt entschieden. Das sage ich jetzt nicht mit Barca-Brille, sondern rein faktisch, 12 Punkte wirst du nicht mehr aufholen als Real Madrid. Das sind ja nur noch, ich glaube, 12 Spiele, wenn ich mich nicht täusche. Also die einen müssen ja nicht nur viermal verlieren, die anderen müssen ja auch alles gewinnen. Das klingt ein bisschen schwierig umzusetzen. Zum anderen ist natürlich Real Madrid noch international dabei. In der Champions League Barca nicht. Also die, die die Doppelbelastung haben, sind die, die den Rückstand aufholen müssen. Also da ist sich ganz Spanien natürlich einig, bei 12 Punkten Vorsprung ist der Titel Barca nicht mehr zu nehmen. Von daher ist das auch gar nicht mehr so ein großes Thema jetzt durch die Länderspielpause, weil einfach eine Meisterschaft fast de facto entschieden ist. Ein interessanteres Thema war tatsächlich oder ist grundsätzlich natürlich der Abstiegskampf in Spanien, denn da hat sich wieder was getan. Sevilla hat ein bisschen Panik bekommen, hat Angst abzusteigen und hat erneut den Trainer entlassen. Jorge Sampaoli wurde entlassen, der kam ja erst im Spätherbst oder Winter und ist jetzt schon wieder weg. Also da geht es eher ab im Tabellenkeller, wo alles sehr, sehr eng ist und da ist ein Traditionsclub richtig am Schwimmen, sogar zwei. Valencia, die hatten wir ja von meinem letzten Besuch thematisiert. Und Sevilla dachte, dass sie unten ein bisschen raus sind nach Reims, ein paar Siege unter Sampaoli gab, ein paar sehr, sehr wichtige, aber zuletzt eben auch wieder fünf von acht Spielen, wettbewerbsübergreifend, verloren. Teilweise richtige Klatschen kassiert. Bei Atletico Madrid gab es ein 1 zu 6, wo sie auch wirklich wie ein Absteiger spielten. Und wer Atletico nur entfernt kennt, weiß, wann schießen die denn schon mal sechs Tore gegen dich? Also das passiert ja einmal im Schaltejahr. Von daher, da hat Sevilla ein ganz schlechtes Bild abgegeben. In der Europa League sind sie zwar jeweils weitergekommen, aber immer auswärts verloren in Eindhoven und Fenerbahce. Ja, auch nicht die allergrößten Vereine international gesehen. Auch da jeweils mit Achunkrach weitergekommen, trotz Niederlage und ein schlechtes Bild abgegeben. Ja, und so hat man sich erneut vom Trainer getrennt. Und jetzt kommt ein Urgestein zurück. José Luis Mendilibar ist jetzt neuer Trainer von Sevilla und soll sie vom Abstiegs retten. Also so ein richtiger Feuerwehr-Move ist das.
Wie bewertest du denn diesen Abstiegskampf? Ich meine, es ist ja krass. Also es gibt 7 Teams, die innerhalb von 3 bis 4 Punkten liegen. Also Almeria, Valencia 26, Espanol 27, Valadolid, Kadiz und Sevilla 28 und dann Retafel mit 29. Und man könnte sogar, wenn man streng sein will, Girona noch mit reinnehmen. Mit 31 sind die jetzt auch nicht so krass weit weg. Also es ist sehr, sehr eng. Haben wir ja das letzte Mal hier auch schon thematisiert. Aber da scheint ja jetzt wirklich dann Panik um sich zu greifen.
Ja, absolut. Also bei Sevilla ist das wirklich ziemliche Panik. Das kann man schon so nennen, weil ich glaube, niemand hatte wirklich auf dem Zettel, dass Rosse Luiz Mendilibar da bei Sevilla anheuern könnte. Nur so zum kleinen Kontext, das ist eher so ein Trainer, den Abstiegskandidaten anheuern. Jetzt kannst du sagen, ja natürlich, Sevilla ist ja ein Abstiegskandidat. Ja, das stimmt, aber vom Namen her ist Sevilla ja ein Europa League Champions League Teilnehmer und nicht so ein typisches Team, das da unten drin steht und dann eben einen Feuerwehrmann holt. Also, Mendilibar von der Kragenweite her ist eher so ein Typus, den Cardis oder Valladolid oder Almeria anstellen würde, wenn die eben im April oder im März merken, shit, wir brauchen irgendwie jetzt noch einen Feuerwehrmann. Dass ihn also Sevilla holt, spricht halt einfach Bände. Er ist ein absolutes Urgestein in La Liga. Von den aktiven Liga-Coaches hat nur Ernesto Valverde, der Ex-Barca-Coach, jetzt Athletik-Club der Bilbao-Coach, nur mehr Spiele in der ersten Liga gecoacht als Jose Luis Mendilibar. Also, da sieht man schon, das ist ein Urgestein, das ist eine Legende dieser Liga, aber in aller Regel arbeitet er eben bei Abstiegskandidaten von der Kragenweite, Valladolid und Co. und eben nicht beim FC Sevilla. Also, dass die den jetzt holen, ist ein ganz klares Zeichen, dass sie wirklich Panik haben, dass sie da ganz unten reinrutschen können, und zwar bis zum Schluss.
Krass. Letzte Station war Alaves von Mendy Liba. Da war er allerdings auch nur für 12 Spiele.
Genau, die sollte er letztes Jahr vom Abstieg retten, wurde da auch irgendwann im Frühjahr oder so angeheuert und hat es halt nicht geschafft und wurde danach, nachdem es gar nicht lief, direkt wieder entlassen. Also, das ist eben, sage ich ja, das ist so ein Move, wie man ihn erwartet, dass so ein Trainer bei so einem Verein irgendwie was retten soll. Aber dass ihn Sevilla holt, spricht einfach Bände, dass denen auch das Wasser bis zum Halt steht und dass sie auch einfach Schiss haben, Panik haben.
Gut, mit Blick auf die Tabelle. Sehr gut nachvollziehbar, dass da vielleicht eine gewisse Grundpanik besteht. Dann wollen wir nochmal auf die Serie A blicken und da beschäftigen wir uns jetzt nicht mit dem Abstiegskampf, sondern mit dem aktuellen Tabellen 2. 19 Punkte Rückstand sind es hier, also auch hier die Liga entschieden. Ist ja auch eine interessante Konstellation. Auf einmal ist es überall in Europa entschieden, aber in der Bundesliga spannend, wie man es macht irgendwie. Immer ist es komisch und so, dass die Deutschen sich beschweren. Aber wir wollen jetzt über Lazio sprechen, unter Sarri. Was ist denn da passiert, Bernie, in den letzten Wochen?
Ja, also du sprichst ja an, dass Lazio auf 2 steht. Ich glaube, ich hätte jetzt auch nicht alle damit gerechnet. Es klingt schon so weit weg, aber es war ja das letzte Spiel vor der Pause. Das war das Derby in Rom, das Lazio zum zweiten Mal in dieser Saison gewonnen hat. Das war wieder mal ein typisches Rom-Derby. Ich nenne es mal unter Anführungszeichen hektisch. Da ging es drunter und drüber. Es gab auch Fassen, in denen nicht so viel Fußball gespielt wurde. Nach dem Schlusspfiff noch rote Karten. Also das ist komplett der Rom-Derby-Programm. Aber eben, es passt jetzt perfekt. Lazio ist jetzt zweiter. Und wenn man sich anschaut – und das ist wirklich, finde ich, sehr überraschend – Lazio ist in dieser Saison unter Sarri gegen die Top-Gegner in Italien extrem stark. Sie haben jetzt beide Derbys gegen die Roma gewonnen. Das macht ja schon mal in Rom, bereitet ja schon mal ein sehr schönes Jahr, wenn du das als Trainer, als Mannschaft schaffst. Aber sie haben vor kurzen, vor wenigen Wochen in Neapel gewonnen bei Napoli, was in der Saison noch nicht vielen Mannschaften gelungen ist. Sie haben Inter geschlagen. Sie haben Milan vor wenigen Wochen 4-0. Also das war eine Demonstration. Klar, das war diese Phase im Januar, als Milan so extrem im Negativstrudel war. Aber trotzdem, ich habe es mir herausgeschrieben, in sieben direkten Duellen gegen die Top-Teams haben sie 15 Punkte geholt. Und damit gleich viele wie Napoli. Also das zeigt, Sarri hat es geschafft, dass Lazio in dieser Saison wirklich nicht umsonst im Moment auf Platz 2 steht, sondern sie haben da wirklich einen Entwicklungsschritt gemacht, gerade gegen die Großen. Und man muss da vielleicht ein bisschen ausholen. Es ist ja Sarris zweites Jahr. Letztes Jahr, ich glaube, es gibt wenig größere Fußballphilosophie-Unterschiede, als von einem Simone Insargi zu Marizio Sarri zu wechseln. Also Lazio wart ja jahrelang unter Insargi, dieses 3-5-2-Abwartend-Umschaltspiel, das war sozusagen in der Lazio-DNA drin. Und dann kam Sarri und mit Sarri kommt halt ungefähr das genaue Gegenteil an Fußballphilosophie. Ballbesitz, 4-3-3, Raumverteidigung, hochstehende Kette. Also das Muster hat ein Jahr gebraucht, bis er sozusagen wirklich auch in die Köpfe der Spieler reingekommen ist. Und jetzt aber fruchtet das. Und es ist für mich auch ein schöner kleiner Wink Richtung Turin zu Juve. Vielleicht lohnt es sich, wenn man sich einen Trainer wie Maurizio Sarri holt, was der Juve auch mal gemacht hat, dass man dem auch noch ein zweites Jahr ergibt, weil der gute Mann in Sachen, was seine Fußballlehrertätigkeit betrifft, glaube ich, schon was vorweisen kann. Und dazu passte eben auch vor wenigen Wochen eben, wie gesagt, Lazio bei Napoli gewonnen, da hat Spalletti wirklich auch ein Loblied auf Sarri gesungen, er hat gemeint, hat immer wieder durchklingen lassen. Er profitiert sehr von der Arbeit, die Sarri vor einigen Jahren eben mit Napoli gestartet hat, wo Napoli diese erste Hochphase hatte. Ich finde, das wunderschöne Zitat von Spalletti ist für mich eines der Fußballzitate des Jahres, zumindest in Italien. Er hat gemeint, in Castel Volturno, also im Trainingszentrum von Neapel, sieht man auf dem Rasen noch die Pastlinien von Sarri. Also er hat wirklich auch damit klargemacht, dass dieser Scudetto, den Spalletti jetzt logischerweise mit Napoli mit links einfahren wird, dass Spalletti da eben auch auf der Basis von Sarri sozusagen profitiert hat. Und deswegen finde ich schön, dass Sarri jetzt eben in dieser zweiten Saison mit Lazio wirklich diesen Entwicklungsschritt macht. Er hat es gemacht, auch ganz interessant, indem er die Defensive gestärkt hat. Er hat im Sommer schon erkannt, auch in Sachen Transfers. Er hat komplett die Innenverteidigung neu besetzt, beide Torhüter neu und das fruchtet. Romagnoli kam von Milan, stabilisiert da innen drin. Dazu hat er mit Casale einen jungen Italiener geholt von Hellas. Die harmonieren wunderbar. Lazio hat jetzt, glaube ich, 19 Gegentore. Er ist jetzt die zweitbeste Abwehr, 16 Mal schon zu Null. Ich glaube, nur Barca hat in den Top-5-Ligen in Europa öfter zu Null eben gespielt.
Die haben nur neun Gegentore, Barca.
Ja, genau. Und damit aber jetzt nicht falsch verstehen, ist es jetzt nicht so, dass Sarri hinten drin steht und tief steht, sondern es ist der Sarri-Fußball 433, extrem viel Pallbesitz. Und er hat auch in dieser Saison noch schön Schritt für Schritt Entwicklung. Am Anfang der Saison haben zum Beispiel so Schlüsselspieler wie Luis Alberto oder auch Lazari, die saßen noch viel auf der Bank, weil eben das war ihm noch zu offensiv. Die mussten da irgendwie noch erst reinkommen. Lazari ist ein Außenverteidiger, der seine Qualitäten ganz eindeutig im Offensivspiel hat. Da hat ihm die Balance noch gefehlt, deswegen hat er die rausgelassen, hat sie aber Stück für Stück rein gearbeitet. Und jetzt spielt Lazari, jetzt spielt Luis Alberto, jetzt hast du dieses dominante Mittelfeld mit Luis Alberto und mit Milinkovic Savic. Du hast vorne drin Immobile, Philippe Anderson, Zaccani und Pedro, also wirklich auch Qualität. Und du hast das Ganze auf einem sehr gut strukturierten Spiel gegen den Ball, Defensive. Und deswegen würde ich sagen, also wirklich aus sportlicher Sicht, was Sarri da mit Lazio macht, auch mit dem Kader, den Lazio hat, weil das ist ja auch so eine Geschichte, die Lazio schon seit vielen Jahren begleitet. Die ersten 12, 13 Spieler sind top, aber danach ist ein extremer Abfall, gerade auch Leistungsabfall, wenn du dir das mit den anderen Top-Kadern in Italien anschaust. Und dieses Jahr gelingt es ihm da, in der Liga im Moment wirklich sehr, sehr gute Karten im Rennen und die Champions League zu haben.
Und das setzt eben alle unter Druck. Ist ja klar, wenn Lazio da reinrutscht unter die ersten vier, dann rutscht irgendjemand raus. Aktuell ist es die Roma, aber die sind auch nur ein Punkt hinter Milan und nur drei Punkte hinter Inter. Und Atalanta klopft auch fröhlich in die Liga.
Absolut, die sind auch noch dran. Und wie gesagt, Juve haben wir schon mal angerissen, mal wer weiß. Jetzt gibt es im April dann einen Rekurs, der verhandelt wird. Rein sportlich wäre Juve auf zwei, wenn man die 15 Punkte sozusagen dazunimmt. Also der Champions League-Kampf in Italien – klar, du hast es gesagt, Meisterschaft brauchen wir schon seit Wochen nicht mehr reden, aber der Kampf um die Champions League-Plätze ist wirklich sehr, sehr heiß. Und dass Lazio da wirklich eine so gute Rolle dieses Jahr spielt, hätte ich mir am Saisonstart nicht gedacht. Kurze Klammer noch, was wieder typisch Lazio ist, sie können die Doppelbelastung mit... Ja, erst sind sie aus der Europa League schon raus, jetzt sind sie in die Conference League und jetzt sind sie wieder raus. Also das kriegen sie einfach nicht hin, aber da sind wir wieder beim Thema. Die Breite ist nicht da, aber ich würde auch sagen, das ist so eine Geschichte, die hat sich im Verein verankert. Europa League und Conference League spielen bei diesem Verein einfach keine Rolle. Dementsprechend schafft es Sarri zumindest in dieser Zone, die Energie so zu kanalisieren, dass sie jetzt in der Liga wirklich es selbst in der Hand haben. Und wer weiß, sollten sie in die Champions League kommen, das hat zumindest Simonin Sargi vor ein paar Jahren vorgemacht. Da sind sie dann schon auch unter Sargi aus der Gruppenphase raus. Erinnert ihr euch vielleicht noch, sind dann gegen die Bayern im Achtelfinale raus. Also ich glaube schon, dass in der Champions League wäre das logischerweise ein anderes Setting, Mindsetting. Aber Europa League und Conference League kannst du mit Lazio vergessen. Das wird nicht funktionieren.
Zwei mal eins, zwei gegen Eichmann. Hat man nicht im Rückspiel sogar geführt mit 1 zu 0? Dann hat das Eichmann also – naja gut. Aber so ist das eben. Jetzt wollen wir nochmal in die Liga gucken. David, da hast du uns noch ein überraschendes Thema mitgebracht, worüber ich mich sehr freue. Du wirst über Reims sprechen. Was ist da zu wissen?
Genau. Ich habe ein bisschen überlegt, habe ein bisschen geschaut über die Vereine, die ihr gesprochen habt in der Vergangenheit und dachte, ich bringe mal Reims mit. Und zum Einstieg, da ich ja jetzt tatsächlich ein paar Mal auch selbst jetzt höherer der Ligatur war und längere Zeit nicht dabei ist, mir aufgefallen, dass du – Ligaturist warst du. Ich war ein Ligaturist. Aber dann geht doch dein wunderschönes Wortspiel mit der Schrift als Ligatur von dort.
Ja, das stimmt eigentlich nicht. Aber das hat anscheinend eh niemand verstanden, warum es Ligatur heißt.
Also ich habe es nicht verstanden. Da stehe ich auch dazu.
Ligatur ist quasi ein – das kommt aus dem Schriftsetzen. Das ist das Verbinden von zwei Buchstaben. Und wir verbinden ja hier mehrere Ligen miteinander. Also es war eigentlich ein wunderschönes Wortspiel. Die Ligatur, die eben nicht nur eine Tour ist, sondern eben aus der Ligatur kommt. Aber es hat wirklich niemand verstanden. Außer vielleicht noch zwei andere Nerds da draußen.
Ist doch dann nur mit U, nicht mit OU.
Jaja, genau, klar, logisch.
Max, du weißt ja, was das über den Künstler sagt, wenn er sein Werk erklären muss, ne?
Ja, das kenne ich von meinen Witzen. Das hättest du nicht noch mal extra sagen müssen.
Also jedenfalls, da ich ja jetzt auch ein paar Mal zugehört habe, ist mir aufgefallen, dass so sehr ich Fußball interessiert bin und dass es häufig doch Städte und Vereine gibt, wo ich echt, also tatsächlich sagen müsste, ich könnte die Städte nicht auf der Landkarte finden in Spanien und ich weiß über die Vereine eigentlich gar nicht so viel. Deswegen mal die Frage an euch in die Runde. Was verwendet ihr mit Ras?
Ich weiß, dass man das S sagen soll am Schluss.
Den Verein irgendwas so? Wie? Historisch? Ist spannend.
Also ich verbinde mit dem Verein, das Usman Demirle da gespielt hat, um ehrlich zu sein. Liegt da jetzt ein bisschen nahe. Aber ansonsten, so historisch gesehen, wenig irgendwie.
War das nicht so der SC Freiburg, der liegt ein? Hab ich mir das richtig gemerkt oder ist das.
Ich gebe euch mal ganz kurz einen Aufriss. Also die Stadt liegt in der Champagne, Nordosten Frankreich, 200.000 Einwohner. Ist bekannt durch Kaiser-Krönungen, da könnte man das gehört haben. Jean D'Arc hat das damals zurückerobert, zum Beispiel, damit da Kaiser Karl VII gegründet wurde. Und das war nach dem 2. Weltkrieg. Darauf wollte ich hinaus. Der dominierende Fußballclub Frankreich. Die hatten 6 Titel, die hatten zahlreiche Pokale, die haben einen Großteil der Spieler bei der WM in Schweden 58 gestellt und waren zweimal im Finale des Europapokals der Landesmeister.
Ja gut, das hätte Uli jetzt wissen können, das ist ja schon Grundwissen.
Ich habe das ja nicht mal kommentiert, deswegen hätte ich das irgendwo stehen, aber ich habe es nicht im Kopf. Erprägende Duelle gegen Real Madrid, beide 56 und 59. Und mit Ramon Copa und Albert Bartheu und wie wohl diese Offensiv-Fußball damals genannt, wenn ein Club in der Champagne liegt. Wer da mehr hören möchte, es gab vom Hörfehler-Podcast im Sommer 22. Die Folgen 154 und 155, Geschichte des französischen Fußballs. Da sehr ausführlich und wenn mich nicht alles täuscht, dann ist der dortige Gast Olaf Wutke auch verantwortlich für den wirklich sehr, sehr schönen und exzellenten Wikipedia-Artikel zu raus. Wer da jetzt Lust hat, kann da gerne mal reinschauen. Das ist ein richtig schönes Lesestück. So, also jedenfalls. Dazwischen herrscht große, große Lehre. Die sind 33 Jahre nicht mehr. Klassisch gewesen seit 1979. Sie haben ihre komplette Trophäensammlung damals verkaufen mussten. Die haben sie aber später wiedergekommen, zum Glück. Weil tatsächlich, das ist ein Name. Die mussten in der sechsten Liga neu beginnen. Seit 2012 sind sie so wieder in der ersten Liga dabei, unten rum und jetzt in der aktuellen Phase seit 2018. Das ist ein Club, der mehr in die untere Hälfte gehört. Die Start der aktuellen Saison lief auch sehr holprig, man fiel da direkt unten rein. Dieses Jahr werden in Frankreich vier Teams absteigen. Das ist ja ein ziemlich harter Abstiegskampf, weil die Liga auf 18 Teams verkleinern will. Dann wurde im Oktober der Trainer Oskar Gassier entlassen und der Co-Trainer übernahm Interim. Der Co-Trainer hat jetzt am Wochenende, also nicht jetzt am Wochenende, sondern am letzten Ligaspieltag, sein erstes Ligaspiel verloren. Ras war 19 Spieltage unbesiegt. Habt ihr den Namen Will Still schon mal gehört? Weil der geistete ein bisschen durch die deutschen Fußballgazetten vor ein paar Wochen. Das ist nämlich der Trainer.
Ich habe aufgeschnappt, dass er Französisch mit französischem Akzent und Englisch mit englischem Akzent sprechen kann. Die wirklich wichtigen Dinge aus Frankreich, die bekomme ich mit.
Also der ist Belgier und sein Vater ist Engländer. Der Vater lebt seit 30 Jahren in Belgien. Und was von Will Still dann so rumgeistert als, glaube ich, Geschichte, auf die sich Journalisten immer sehr, sehr gerne stürzen, ist, dass er angeblich sein ganzes Fußballer taktisches Nerdwissen bekommen haben soll, weil er jahrelang Football-Manager gespielt hat.
Ja, doch.
Siehst du, die wichtigen Dinge kriegen wir mit. Und da hat sich Will Still jetzt auch unlängst geäußert, dass er ja irgendwie ganz schön und so weiter, aber das fände er jetzt noch ein bisschen dexpektierlich, dass das jetzt sozusagen die prägende Story ist, mit der er da charakterisierte. Weil natürlich stimmt das nicht so und da gehört auch deutlich mehr dazu.
Das spielt auch man auf FIFA, zur Wahrheit.
Also es gibt die Anekdote, dass eine Freundin seiner Schwester mal zum Abendessen da gewesen sei und irgendwann habe sie gefragt, können wir noch mal über das andere Satz Fußball sprechen. Will Still ist in Belgien aufgewachsen, hat da auch ein bisschen Fußball gespielt. Es heißt, er habe sehr englisch gespielt, viele rote Karten gezogen und hat dann Football-Coaching in Preston studiert, hat die U14 von Preston Northend trainiert und hat dann in Belgien von Yannick Ferrerat bei Saint-Tron, also bei Sint-Trudinese-VV, eine Chance bekommen, Videolist zu sein. Das hieß schon damals, er habe Dinge gesehen, die normal Leute nicht gesehen haben und mit 24 wird er dann in Lyase, jüngster Trainer der belgischen Liga-Geschichte. Der träumt übrigens noch, hat er auch öffentlich gesagt, der träumt von einem Job in der Premier League. Aber ich glaube nicht Tottenham, er sagte, bevor er zu West Ham gehen würde. Und der ist jetzt, wie gesagt, also 19 Spiele ungeschlagen, hat währenddessen nur neun Tore kassiert. Es läuft extrem gut. Bei diesen 19 ungeschlagenen Spielen sind auch zwei Unentschieden gegen PSG mit drin. Und Siege gegen Rennen, gegen Monaco, teilweise spektakuläre Siege gegen Lorient mit einem Hatschig von Balogun. Balogun ist so ein bisschen der, der ist von Arsenal ausgeliehen. Das ist eine der Stürmerentdeckungen in Frankreich. Teilt sich derzeit den zweiten Rang der Torschützenliste mit 17 Treffern. Neben so Leuten wie Lacazette und Ben Yedère hinter Mbappé. Der hätte jetzt gegen Marseille auch beinahe noch das 2. Nachspielzeit erzielt. Der Gänger war an Pfosten. Die letzte Niederlage davor war tatsächlich am 18. September. Da war der Vorgänger Oscar Garcia noch Trainer. Das ist schon teilweise auf Still zurückzugehen. Er hat ein sehr, sehr bislang unverrückbares 4-2-3-1 eingeführt, stehen defensiv sehr stabil, gutes Stellungsspiel, wenig Räume, die sie dem Gegner lassen, pressen aber sehr hoch und haben sehr, sehr variable Spieler vorne, die sich da so gegenseitig in der Offensive auch abwechseln. Da scheint auch keiner sich zu schade zu sein, mal von der Bank zu kommen. Also ein extrem gutes Mannschaftsgefüge da auch. Ob das jetzt tatsächlich für Europa reicht oder ob da Europa nicht sogar zu früh wäre, ist jetzt die Frage.
Immerhin den Abstieg vermieden mit 20 Punkten Vorsprung auf.
Den Abstieg sehr, sehr eindeutig vermieden gerade. Ich habe leider für die Hörer extra nachgeschaut. Also man kann zumindest in den nächsten zwei, drei Wochen auf der Zone-Grenze erstmal nicht sehen, weil die spielen jetzt gegen keine der Top-Klubs und der Zone zeigt ja normalerweise von der Liga nur die Spiele mit Top-Klub-Beteiligung. Die hatten sie ja alle schon hinter sich jetzt.
Aber wir sehen, ist sehr gut. Danke, dass du mich da nochmal dran erinnert hast. Ich habe einen Artikel auf The Athletic über Will Stil gelesen und das ist natürlich ganz fantastisch, wie ich mir da gemerkt habe, bei welchem Verein er überhaupt Trainer ist.
Der kostet doch pro Spiel ein paar Tausend, weil er keine ausreichende Lizenz hat.
Er hat es mittlerweile.
Das sind die spannenden Fakten.
Genau, genau, genau. Ist mittlerweile aber auch schon jetzt Geschichte, weil er hat jetzt offiziell seinen Trainerschein angefangen. Da muss man nicht mehr drüber berichten.
Ja, aber das ist doch schön, wie man dann über den Tabellen neunten der Liga auch sehr interessant sprechen kann. Lieben Dank dir, lieber David. Und ich würde sagen, jetzt zum Abschluss, nachdem die Zeit auch schon ein bisschen fortgeschritten ist, hätte ich gerne die Matches to Watch, also was am Wochenende müssen wir in den einzelnen Ligen beobachten. Da ich vermute, dass Uli Hebel mal wieder die Matches to Watch selbst moderiert, wird er darauf vorbereitet sein. Nein, nein, nein, an dem Wochenende gibt es nur City gegen Liverpool.
Also es ist nichts Erhellendes, nichts Neues, aber das muss man natürlich sehen. Also guter Zeitpunkt auch, 13.30 Uhr geht es da los, also Samstag noch bevor der ganze, also es soll ja in Deutschland auch ein Spiel geben, das einigermaßen interessieren könnte, aber das kann man sich, glaube ich, sehr gut anschauen. Und dann aber Arsenal auch bitte.
Die Frage ist übrigens, kann man sich sehr gut anschauen, wenn man es mit dem FC Liverpool hält, ne? Das ist ja die Thematik.
Ja, gegen CD sah es ja meistens gut aus. Und ich möchte mal auch nahelegen bitte, Plymouth Argyle gegen Bolton Wanderers, EFL-Trophy am Sonntag.
Ja, ja, ich sage einfach nur Ja. Ich sage Ja zu Plymouth gegen Argyle gegen die Bolton Wanderers. Aber es tut mir auch irgendwie ganz gut, dass ich nicht der Größe Nord bin in dieser Sendung. Da fühle ich mich immer so herrlich normal, wenn ich mit euch spreche. Christian, was muss ich in der Serie A verfolgen?
Ja, das ist auch relativ einfach. Da spielen am Sonntagabend Napoli gegen Milan, was ja eh an sich schon ein Kracher ist. Gerade für Milan geht es ja auch darum, im Champions League rennen zu bleiben. Schwer genug. Und Napoli gegen Milan spielen jetzt Mitte April auch noch zweimal gegeneinander, in einem anderen Spiel unter Champions League Aspekten. Dementsprechend dreimal Napoli gegen Milan jetzt in den nächsten Wochen. Da ist ordentlich Zündstoff drin.
Das kann man sich tatsächlich so vorstellen. In der Liga, was ist da wichtig? Gibt es da noch wichtige Spiele, Alex?
Es gibt ein wichtiges Spiel, das aber nicht direkt in der Liga ist, sondern in der Copa del Rey natürlich das Halbfinale-Rückspiel im Pokal. Wieder Klassikos. Man hat ihn ja vermisst. Es gab ja erst vier bisher. Daher gibt es direkt gleich wieder einen am Wochenende. Aber es gibt eher zwei Spiele, die ziemlich spannend sind im Rennen um die Champions League. Nämlich Vireal gegen Real Sociedad, das ist Sechster gegen Vierter und dann Atletico gegen Betis, das ist Dritter gegen Fünfter. Das Rennen um die Champions League ist sehr spannend. Sevilla mit Neu-Coach Mendy Libar hat ein kleines Abstiegs – Endspiel kommt zu früh, es sind ja noch genug Spiele – aber ein Abstiegskracher in Cádiz. Die beiden sind punktgleich.
Das sind auch ein paar Geheimtipps, die ihr hier bekommt.
Kann ja nicht jeder hier mit Liverpool gegen City glänzen.
Ist auch eine der wenigen Vereine, wenn ich das richtig gesehen habe, die Mendy Libar noch nicht trainiert hat, Cádiz.
Wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich. Also tabellarisch einfach spannend. Es gibt einfach Spannenderes als der Meisterschaftskampf, logisch. Von daher, wir pricken ja auf die spannende Paarung.
Aber wirklich. Und was müssen wir uns da in der Liga zu Gemüte führen, David?
Ja, ich habe ja eben schon angedeutet. Ich habe mal geschaut, was wird denn überhaupt übertragen. Rennen gegen Lens kann man sich anschauen. Fünfter gegen Dritter. Die beiden Vereine wurden ja hier, wissen die Ligaturisten, wurden ja auch schon mal in den vergangenen Wochen besprochen. Ansonsten könnte auch – das ist Samstag 9 Uhr abends – und ansonsten könnte durchaus auch das Sonntag um 5 Uhr Spiel ganz interessant sein. Das ist Monaco gegen Strasburg. Da geht es für Monaco auch um Europa. Die sind aktuell zwischen Lens und Rennen eingeklemmt. Und für Strasburg geht es um den Abstiegskampf. Die waren da eigentlich schon ganz, ganz tief unten drin und haben jetzt aber einen kleineren Lauf, bei dem sie sich gerade wieder so ein bisschen rauskämpfen.
Und haben aber auch mit Dia Lo einen sehr erfolgreichen Torschützen vorne drin, den man sich ein bisschen angucken kann. Und bei Monaco haben wir ja Ben Yada sowieso mit dabei.
Genau, ja. Und Ben Seguir, den neuen jungen Shootingstar.
Ihr vier. Das hat wieder große, große Freude gemacht. Das war eine sehr schöne Sendung. Ganz herzlichen Dank an euch alle, dass ihr euch die Zeit genommen habt. Ich danke immer noch neben mir sitzen Christian Bernhard. Danke dir.
Danke schön.
Danke an Uli Hebel. Danke auch. Danke an Alex Truica.
Sehr gerne. Danke ebenfalls.
Und vielen Dank schön, dass du mal wieder da warst. David Frogier de Ponlevoy von 390. Danke dir, lieber David. Und dann wünsche ich euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, eine gute Woche. Viel Spaß mit den ganzen Top-Matches, die ihr jetzt gucken müsst. Sagt nicht, wir hätten es euch nicht gesagt, um was es da geht am Wochenende. Und dann hören wir uns hier wieder im Rasenfunk. Die nächste Rasenfunk-Schlusskonferenz wird Tobi Escher moderieren, den nächsten Frauen-Kurzpass, der erscheint am Montag. Die moderiere dann wieder ich. Und es gibt dann auch was zur 2. Männer-Bundesliga, das kommt in der nächsten Woche am Donnerstag. Bis dahin bleibt gesund und unterstützt bitte den Rasenfunk. Danke euch, liebe Grüße, ciao!